en agriculture comme dans d'autres
domaines on n'arrête pas le progrès la
preuve ce reportage de 1987 sur un
prototype de tracteurs révolutionnaire
un tracteur robot conçu pour alléger la
tâche des agriculteurs
[Musique]
hu
un tracteur roulant seul dans un champ
sans permis au volant ça surprend
d'issue son chauffeur
le voici un ordinateur pièce centrale et
maîtresses du système informatisé de
navigation du tout nouveau tracteur
rouge malgré qu'on allait climatisé puis
la radio on attendait lorsqu'ils
parcourent cette ère le fermier au
volant de son tracteur privé de points
de repère précis repas souvent
involontairement au même endroit on
estime qu'en moyenne 10 % de la
superficie du chant est ainsi visité à
plusieurs reprises par le véhicule de
l'agriculteur une situation qui coûte
cher tout d'abord en essence puisque le
tracteur travail inutilement on semences
et en engrais aussi et y en ait
scepticisme et herbicides de toutes
sortes et pendu en trop grande quantité
le système indique continuellement où
vous êtes et d'un des points de repère
précis qui vous ramène otage et que vous
devez suivre comme le pilotage
automatique dans un avion la technologie
a fait des pas de géant depuis la
présentation de ce reportage
aujourd'hui les tracteurs équipés de
systèmes de guidage par gps sont
monnaies courantes et l'agriculture de
précision permet des applications
ciblées de pesticides et d'engrais
mais pour des raisons de sécurité même
si le tracteur peut conduire tout seul
il doit encore y avoir un humain
derrière le volant